emily is my you know i adore her and
always will it's no surprise a-list
actors have crossed each other's paths
before and found romance along the way
hollywood is a pretty tight circle what
is surprising is just how many marvel
actors had a fling with their co-stars
all these marvel characters dating irl
is putting us in the mood to create a
shipping verse let's check out who got
with who was your first ever celebrity
crush
um
number one if you don't already know the
news you've been living under a rock or
trying desperately to avoid those no way
home spoilers after being outed by the
media tom and zendaya have taken to
instagram to call each other my
spider-man and my mj but their romance
has spanned far longer than 2021 perhaps
going all the way back to 2016. they've
been on plenty of vacations together and
share a similar sense of humor they're a
very private couple however so don't go
digging into their personal lives got it
the heart is uncontrollable you can't
legislate for who you fall in love with
you just happen number two there's still
a chance if we protest we can make this
a thing on screen too tom hiddleston and
zoey ashton starred in betrayal together
in 2019 as lovers their relationship was
only confirmed when they set foot on the
red carpet of the 2021 tony awards
together but it isn't the first time
they've been seen spending time together
are you racking your brain trying to
think of what character zoie ashton
played don't worry she hasn't joined the
mcu just yet she's set to play a villain
in the marvels which is in
post-production right now
it's so hard for me to believe that
she's someone's aunt number three while
we love happy hogan we would totally
ship tony stark and aunt may in an
alternate universe in the early 90s
robert downey jr and marissa tomei
starred in chaplain together but their
romance didn't spark until the mid-90s
when they starred in the romantic movie
only you the relationship only lasted a
year but they remain friends your family
just do weird stuff
my girlfriend was just looking on in
horror i think she said you are like the
middle class shameless
number four since cersei has been on
earth seven thousand years who's to say
she and howard stark couldn't have a
love story gemma chan who played cersei
in eternals and dominic cooper who
played tony stark's dad howard are a
thing and have been since 2018. a date
night for them would be the day they
brought 80 meals to the frontline
workers in london in the earliest stages
of the pandemic at least that's all
they've really felt comfortable opening
up about what i've learned about love is
oh i can't say it's too cheesy number
five once again gods and prequels it
isn't out of the question richard madden
who played icarus in eternals and jenna
coleman who played connie in captain
america the first avenger dated on and
off from 2012 to 2015. madden totally
geeked out over coleman landing her role
in doctor who
number 6. black widow and deadpool
sounds like either the best couple or
the worst no exceptions scarlett
johansson and ryan reynolds dated in
2007 they were married the next year and
stayed married until the end of 2010
when they decided to divorce i never
thought that i'd be planning my wedding
in like a dark alley somewhere but it
turned out that way it was really quite
secretive i felt like i was doing a drug
deal without all the fun number seven we
would support a multiverse where this
exists too if the stars are aligning
like we think they are elizabeth olsen
and tom hiddleston might be acting
across from each other in the future
maybe as soon as doctor strange too even
he'd met actually doing a chemistry for
something that neither of us got and i
remember walking out and being like that
was a really fun audition they dated in
2015 after co-starring in i saw the
light for less than a year they cozied
up during movie premieres but by the
sounds of it olson had just called off
her engagement and wasn't looking for
anything too serious and the media blew
it up like wow my life's real exciting i
got three avengers on my on my cue
number eight star-lord and sharon carter
are definitely more shippable than
shipping bright and amy abbott chris
pratt and emily vancamp started dating
when they played siblings on a tv show
called everwood their relationship
lasted from 2004 to 2007. and yes people
did tell them they found it weird they
were dating their on-screen sibling
chris had said yeah we've pretty much
gotten used to the response of ew that's
weird that's creepy
is it true she was your childhood
celebrity crush yes that's absolutely
true number nine the most successful
couple both happened to play tony
stark's ai that feel when robots are
better at love paul bettany and jennifer
connolly actually met on the set of the
award-winning movie a beautiful mind
they've been married since 2003 and are
raising three children together paul's
eldest son kai is 23 and their youngest
child agnes is just 9 years old when
paul and jennifer initially met on set
both of them were in separate
relationships betany proposed to
connelly before they'd even dated after
realizing how worried he was about her
when the september 11th attacks happened
number 10 we can't say we ship the
raccoon and gamora one bit zoe saldana
and bradley cooper met on the romantic
drama film the worlds where they played
fictional lovers they dated for about a
year from 2011 and broke up just before
new years of 2012. number 11. daredevil
and pepper potts a rather interesting
combo ben affleck and gwyneth paltrow
dated on and off for three years from
1997 to 2000 after meeting on the set of
shakespeare in love the two are still
friendly affleck was also married to
jennifer garner who starred in elektra
in 2005. they were actually married from
2005 to 2018. number 12 the male
spider's ability to hypnotize females
must be strong toby maguire and kirsten
dunst dated during the first spider-man
movie in 2001 but broke up before the
second one this upset james franco
because he'd had a crush on kirsten
dunst too despite the breakup mcguire
and dunst managed to keep the chemistry
between the characters alive number 13
the most poetic spider's relationship
emma kept on texting me and she was like
are you in this new spider-man film and
i was like i don't know what you're
talking about and then she saw it she's
like you're a jerk andrew garfield and
emma stone dated from 2012 to 2015 while
they were filming the amazing spider-man
series andrew said of the relationship
it was like i woke up when she came in
it was like diving into white water
rapids and having no desire to hang on
to the side throughout shooting it was
wild and exciting they've remained
friends since parting it's like a dream
to work with him here's hoping the fate
of the current spidey doesn't follow the
same timeline as his predecessors we
love tom and zendaya number 14 would
jane foster be able to put up with
mysterio's big ego jake gyllenhaal and
natalie portman dated in both 2002 and
2006 natalie portman remembers being
drawn to jake because he was mysterious
just kidding the two are still pretty
friendly too gyllenhaal went so far as
to say i first met natalie at a star
wars convention waiting in line for her
to sign my queen amidala doll and i'm
really hoping she wins the oscar why you
may ask because then his doll will be
worth a whole lot of money number 15.
the two perverted homer simpsons that's
how j-law described their relationship
x-men first-class actors jennifer
lawrence who played raven darkhome and
nicholas holt who played hank mccoy met
on set and dated for five years jennifer
lawrence joked that they broke up over
silly things like nicholas not wringing
out his sponges and you know what these
two did for fun they liked to play
basketball okay so try not falling in
love with your devilishly handsome super
charming ultra successful co-star we
dare you what couple surprised you the
most and who do you think would make the
weirdest couple in the mcu and beyond
we're putting our money on rocket
raccoon and gamora but let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
watching